To make a car, you need some seriously heavy
metal.
Take iridium, a super tough atom with 77
protons.
That's used to coat the tips.
Of spark plugs.
Next on the heavyweight lineup comes gold
with 79 protons.
This shiny conductor resists corrosion,
making it ideal for exposed electrical
connections.
These connectors here for this airbag
assembly are gold.
And so this thing can react really quickly
if there's an accident and save your life.
The biggest atom in a car is lead with 82
protons.
Only lead has the durability to deliver the
short burst of high power needed to start an
engine over and over again.
But until very recently, how the universe
made these oversized atoms was a complete
mystery.
You can't make gold atoms in a normal star.
You can't make gold atoms in a massive star
that's dying.
In order to make atoms this big with this
many neutrons, you need a truly cataclysmic
event.
Just a few years ago, most scientists
believed that supernovas were cataclysmic
enough to do the job.
But astronomer Edo Berger was not so sure.
If you open any one of these books and flip
to the page that tells you where gold came
from, it will tell you that gold came from
supernova explosions.
But nobody had directly observed supernovas
producing elements like gold and inside
computer simulations.
Virtual supernovas lacked the energy to
forge these oversized atoms.
Clearly, something was wrong.
But if supernovas weren't powerful enough,
what in the universe was.
To form heavy elements requires a lot of
neutrons.
And so another possible theory was that the
heaviest elements were produced in the
mergers of two neutron stars in a binary
system.
Neutron stars are some of the weirdest
objects in the universe.
They're formed from the collapsed cores of
big stars when they die.
You're taking a couple of times the mass of
the sun and squeezing it down into a ball
that's only a few miles across.
The electrons and the protons that are
flitting around inside of that combine to
form neutrons.
And what you're left with is an extremely
dense ball of neutrons about the size of a
city.
Neutron stars are extremely dense.
If you take just a teaspoon of the neutron
star material, it's actually a billion tons.
If neighboring stars die together, it's
possible for the two neutron stars they leave
behind to form a spinning binary pair.
But the partnership is doomed.
What you're left over with is two incredibly
compact, dramatic objects spiraling around
each other. Over time, they move in together
until finally they can coalesce in the most
violent explosion since the Big Bang.
The explosion is called a neutron star
merger.
The amount of energy in this explosion is
crushing.
There's almost no way to describe it.
It's like taking all of the sun's energy
that it will ever emit over its entire
lifetime and releasing it in a single
second.
Berger suspects this colossal explosion
forges iridium gold and lead.
But to rewrite the textbooks, he needs hard
evidence.
It was difficult to convince the community
that this was a potential channel for the
production of heavy elements.
The proof is to actually see this process
happening in the universe.
June 2013, NASA's Swift satellite spots a
short burst of gamma rays from a nearby
galaxy. A sure sign that a neutron star
merger has just taken place.
For Berger, it's the lucky break he's been
waiting for.
As soon as we knew that there was a gamma ray
burst nearby, we knew that this was our one
chance for perhaps several years to obtain
the right kind of measurements to test the
formation of heavy elements.
Once Swift had identified the burst, the
Hubble Space Telescope swung into action to
capture images.
We grabbed them right away and we just
looked.
We knew exactly where to look.
At the center of this red circle.
And what we saw was this source right there
in the middle.
That is the direct signature of the
production of very heavy elements, including
gold.
Berger's theory was right, but the rate of
production was way higher than he'd expected.
Well, in that one event, the amount of gold
that was produced was more than the mass of
the earth. If we can bring it all here, it
would be worth quadrillions and quadrillions
of dollars.
The theory is still very new, but it's
possible that ancient neutron star mergers
made all the heavy metals we see in the
world today, including the last remaining
ingredients for our car.
But all these elements are still floating
free in space.
What's needed now is to pull them all
together into one giant fabrication plant.
The earth. This is what your car looked like
before the earth was born.
Just a vast, swirling cloud of gas and star
dust.
The exploded remains of ancient stars.
The clouds between the stars of the galaxy
are made of everything that the earth, your
body and your car is made of.
There's everything that you need floating in
gaseous form between the stars.
4.5 billion years ago.
The gas and dust collapse once more.
It ignites explosively to create a new star.
Our Sun. Close to the young son.
All of the lighter stuff got blown away.
What was left behind was the heavier, denser
stuff.
There was carbon, there was iron, there was
gold, everything in between.
Over time, these free floating elements begin
to coalesce.
Dust becomes rock.
Rocks joined to form larger objects called
Planetesimals.
Finally, Planetesimals joined to form the
Earth.
Our planet is born with all the ingredients
to build a car.
But those ingredients are about to go their
separate ways.
The Earth is a big planet and it's done
something that not all planets do.
It's differentiated.
It melted.
Copper and lead dissolve in sulfur and float
to the top of the molten earth, making these
metals easy to mine today.
But precious metals like iridium and gold
sink to the core of the earth and most of the
iron sinks with it.
It's kind of a pain, actually.
All the heavy elements that are super
useful, like iron, they've sunk to the middle
of the earth where we can't reach them and
there's not a whole lot of it in the crust.